making a movie isn't child's play even
for a child actor throughout Hollywood
history kids in the industry have been
called upon to act in harrowing roles
that push the limits of their abilities
and according to some critics the
boundaries of good taste here are some
of the most famous examples of underage
actors in mature roles Dakota Fanning
hound dog in 2007 12 year-old Fanning
shocked critics and viewing audiences
alike by taking the role the neglected
abused Llewellyn in this coming-of-age
drama which includes a scene what your
character is raped though the violent
act is strictly implied with shots of
Fanning's face and hands the film was
subject to intense backlash from viewers
critics and activist groups who felt
that the young actress shouldn't have
been allowed to join the production
Fanning responded to criticism by
pushing back saying it's a movie and
it's called acting I wanted to do the
film because I thought it might help one
person that has happened to and help
them overcome adversity in their lives
unfortunately Fanning's hopes of
reaching abuse survivors were
effectively undermined by the
controversy which killed the film's buzz
hound dog only earned one hundred and
thirty one thousand dollars against its
three million dollar budget after a
limited release Natalie Portman the
professional seventeen years before she
danced her way to an Oscar win Portman
made her big screen debut in this 1993
thriller as Matilda a little girl whose
family is murdered by a corrupt DEA
agent when she takes refuge with a
neighbor who happens to be a hit man he
becomes her mentor in all things
vengeance our relationship tinged by an
uneasy chemistry between the two at 12
years old Portman was the exact same age
as the character she was playing and
watching her smoke shoot and even hold a
gun to her own head made for a shocking
spectacle albeit one that proved she was
a star who could handle the most
challenging roles out there when shot
not bad huh Kirsten Dunst interview with
the vampire this list wouldn't be
complete without this chilling
performance by Dunst in one of her very
first feature film roles in Anne Rice's
Vampire Chronicles Dunst character
Claudia was only five years old when she
was turned into a vampire but even for
Hollywood that would have been pushing
it instead the role went to the 11-year
old actress who went all out to capture
the anger violence a near insanity of an
adult woman who's trapped for eternity
in the body of a little girl
as disturbing as it was to see dunce
tackle the challenging material she did
do an amazing job earning a Golden Globe
nomination and a permanent spot on the
a-list for her performance Christian
Bale Empire of the Sun long before he
became famous for American Psycho The
Machinist or The Dark Knight trilogy
Christian Bale won critical acclaim for
playing the role of Jim in the 1987
Steven Spielberg war film Empire of the
Sun the movie is essentially a
coming-of-age drama set during Japan's
occupation of China during World War two
and Bale was just 13 when he took on the
challenging role of a boy who goes from
living a comfortable life with his
family and Shanghai to growing up behind
the barbed wire of a Japanese internment
camp spielberg doesn't pull any punches
with Empire of the Sun and despite being
just a child himself Bale delivers an
emotional and commanding performance as
a boy
faced with the horrors of war Macaulay
Culkin the good son evil kids have been
a staple of thriller in horror movies
over the years but that didn't stop
audiences from being alarmed by the
sight of little Kevin McCallister from
home alone playing this cold-blooded
pint-sized psychopath in the good son
there's no supernatural element driving
Henry's penchant for murder he's just
plain bad when his cousin Mark played by
Elijah Wood comes to visit Henry's
family during winter vacation things
turn decidedly dark it's hard to decide
what's more disturbing watching a 12
year old try to kill everyone that
crosses him don't push me
or to pretend that it wasn't hilarious
to watch the same little kid perpetrate
savage acts of violence against two
bumbling criminals in a John Hughes
Christmas comedy just three years
earlier
because of the obvious home alone
parallels the good son wasn't really
scary enough to make anyone scream
except maybe Culkin's parents who had to
watch McCauley very convincingly attempt
to murder his real-life sister Quinn in
scenes like this one Jodie Foster taxi
driver foster stirred up quite a
controversy when she appeared as child
prostitute iris in Martin Scorsese's
1976 classic taxi driver you talking to
me well not the central figure of the
film
iris still plays an important part when
her path crosses with a troubled Travis
Bickel played by Robert De Niro and
foster was just 12 when she played the
role for that reason Scorsese took
precautions his young star was subjected
to psych evaluations to make sure she
could handle the job and her older
sister Connie was used as a stand-in for
sexually suggestive scenes Olivia Hussey
in Claire Danes Romeo and Juliet
Shakespeare's famous play centers on a
pair of star-crossed teenage lovers but
it's also full of sex violence and
suicide that means that casting actual
teenagers in the lead roles has
historically raised some eyebrows first
came Franco Zeffirelli's 1968 adaptation
in which actress Olivia Hussey was only
15 and her Romeo Leonard whiting was 17
thirty years later director Baz Luhrmann
went with an older Romeo in the form of
Leonardo DiCaprio who was 21 at the time
but Claire Danes who played Juliet was
just 16 which made her two years older
than her character but in some folks
opinions still much too young to be
playing a scene like this
on screen Jacob Reynolds Gummo not many
entries on the list can top 1997's
experimental dystopian art film Gummo
when it comes to making audiences squirm
written and directed by Harmony Korine
Gummo chronicles the lives of several
residents of Xenia Ohio following the
effects of a devastating tornado the
movie comprises an interconnected series
of scenes that offer a glimpse into
depravity demoralisation and the depths
of poverty with its linchpin performance
by 13 year old Jacob Reynolds as Solomon
a kid whose hobbies include killing cats
huffing glue and paying a
developmentally disabled girl to have
sex with him most critics panned Gummo
for its pervasive graphic content but it
was lauded by a few filmmakers including
famed director Verner Hertz
who particularly liked this scene
featuring Solomon chowing down on junk
food in a bathtub sue Lyon and Dominique
Swain Lolita the premise of Vladimir
Nabokov's classic novel about a
middle-aged man's sexual obsession with
an adolescent girl makes it tough to
adapt for the screen especially when it
comes to casting the title character but
that hasn't stopped directors from
trying
in 1962 Stanley Kubrick did a more
oblique take on the material with James
Mason as Humbert Humbert and sue lion as
Lolita at 14 Lyon was two years older
than her character and Kubrick was
careful to skirt the sexual content of
Napa coffs novel have you told her
anything about us no have you but the
film and lions roll and it's still
proved controversial and this is one
topic that hasn't become less of a hot
potato with the passage of time when
director Adrian Lyne made his own Lolita
more than 30 years later with
fifteen-year-old Dominique Swain in the
title role the movie was forced to
premiere on cable when it couldn't find
an American distributor and critics in
England even tried to get the film ban
the entire cast of kids this film
centers on the lives of several
teenagers and their sex lives during the
height of the AIDS epidemic and it
doesn't shy away from showing teenagers
in some seriously disturbing situations
the characters and kids engage in a lot
of risky behaviors from doing drugs to
having unprotected sex with adolescent
virgins and the cast was made up of
entirely teenagers which made for plenty
of controversy when the film premiered
with an nc-17 rating all these years
later it's still a polarizing work of
art Brooke Shields pretty baby and the
Blue Lagoon as a girl actress Brooke
Shields appeared in two different movies
that placed her front and center in the
debate about children and on-screen
sexuality at age 12 she starred in
pretty baby as a child prostitute living
with her mother in a New Orleans brothel
at the turn of the 20th century the film
and shields nudity in it was criticized
by many and the movie was even banned in
two Canadian provinces
[Music]
okay you certainly did it didn't you
however the backlash didn't put the
actress off controversial material just
two years later Shields appeared in the
Blue Lagoon as a shipwrecked girl
growing up on an island with only her
cousin played by Christopher Atkins for
company as they reach puberty they
eventually fall in love and even have a
child a plot point which raised eyebrows
as did several nude scenes involving the
fourteen-year-old shields Linda Blair
The Exorcist widely recognized as one of
the greatest horror movies of the 20th
century The Exorcist was also extremely
controversial with fame critic Roger
Ebert even suggesting it deserved an X
rating instead of the R it was given by
the MPAA even though he loved it that's
partly because of its horrifying subject
matter but the presence of an actual
thirteen-year-old girl in the role of a
possessed Regan MacNeil was also
considered problematic Linda Blair's
performance was central to some of the
most disturbing disgusting obscene and
vulgar sequences in the film although
she pushed back against rumors that
being in the movie had psychologically
scarred her she explained a lot of
untruthful stories were made up about me
being mentally disturbed by the movie
I never was because I never bought into
the whole devil thing instead it was the
physical demands of the Exorcist that
had a prolonged impact Blair fractured
her spine while filming this levitation
scene an injury that would later develop
into scoliosis and caused the actress
ongoing health problems well into
adulthood Tatum O'Neal Paper Moon this
1973 comedy drama is a lot more tame
than some of the other entries on this
list but it definitely has its moments
like this one or its nine-year-old star
casually enjoys a cigarette before
bedtime
Tatum O'Neal and real-life father Ryan
O'Neal play characters named addi and
Moe's a pair of unlikely partners in
crime on a cross-country road trip
throughout the film we watched the
absolutely tiny Tatum smoke drink and
con people out of their money like an
old pro and when most starts to neglect
a D in favor of an exotic dancer named
Trixie played by Madeline Kahn the
jealous girl even devises her own con to
get tricks he dumped the movie might
have been more controversial if Tatum
hadn't been so talented in the role her
performance earned widespread acclaim
and she ultimately won an Academy Award
for the part making her the youngest
oscar-winner in history chloe moretz
kick ass at the age of 11 Moretz landed
her most controversial role vigilante
superhero hit girl in the 2010 movie
kick-ass compared to most little girls
and also two most grown men and women
hit girl is a hardened and nihilistic
figure punctuating her frequent murders
with obscenity Laden one-liners kick-ass
met with backlash for its violence and
language with many critics especially
horrified by Moretz character and it
received a well-deserved R rating from
the MPAA which meant that its most
hardcore tween aged hero wasn't able to
watch herself drop f-bombs and kick ass
without adult supervision okay geez
thanks for watching click the looper
icon and subscribe to our youtube
channel + check out all this cool stuff
we know you'll love -
[Music]